та про по-новому списку кандидатів
здувало самі депутати фракції БПП
відсотка свої старі фейсбуки
напасів парламент or мустафа наймемо що
правда на називає конкретних заклик
вибрати і мрії у соціальних міражах
активно говорила сама імена на і речей
поду викакала кандидатура на посаду
міністра охорони здоров'я олексій
інтервали гончаренка годину перебував у
спочатку в партії регіонів
а потім у російському блоки типу дро бути про
біографії рабта виникла записи на і
старовині політика малював і журналісти
на думку шекспір ​​тиф серйозно з
примотати у кандидатуру
столітті inci на роті можливо бік
просто торгуєте я думаю що знає так
часто буваю на переговорах
кожна сторона в вона просить скажемо у
більше нижче ананас правді хоча б
своякіс варіанта річки може ніби не
прийняти не для партнерів, а потім вона ті
варіанти знімай надай шуму та диму на
пост і 3 при форматуванні уряду
за два роки та третій шанс для арсенію
яценюка задихає якщо на пасаті
прем'єр-міністра процес можна точно
каже їх же зараз заповнюють експерти
дар силою фракції самодопомоги занурено
лиж і таку літію легше уряд але новий
тип областю включена і стильний комусь
дати їй думка quality антена лікарі до
слуху і тя navi відкриту конфронтацію не
у ряді
не в адміністрації президента і ти нахуй
трохи бутси у означають йому розвал quality
і дасть рукою і вибори, а за на великих
рейтингом він і затікав вона жадібно
тут турін політична стабільність
поважайте європі може пітер вати виду
віру західних партнерів та париж коду ти
чорновому траншу видом на тіло години
україна мало horn аполітична 5 ринку та
очевидно знайду з чим годині ранку мій
фінансово духового та я думаю я хитатися
та скепсис збоку європейських політиків
зростання
через вас такі внутрішній політичний
шляхи і то відразу мило серце вилетів
велетень обожнювання подалі політичну
правове
фінансова допомога Україні та c повинна
забезпечити
врятувати хлопців з аспаркам ууу вологи заміс
вбити інших реформ і змін на цій чувачок
вали і грому діани на мандат, що дав.
уряду
туди експерт у грі адже його хіба що
сусідня росія та кіно руку
дестабілізація ситуації в Україні